So here we are another Saturday
and so tonight is Since last week
we're doing our questions and answers.
If anybody has any questions, we'll take
[Arabic recitation]
however, I want to ask a question
first.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us in a narration
in Bkari Muslim. As a matter of fact,
this narration
is found in all six books of hadith. All
six original references
which are Bkari Muslimb
that Abbas
said that the prophet Sam
said
He said, "I have been commanded by Allah
to make sujud on seven parts of my
body." So that when a person is in
sujud,
only these seven parts are touching the
ground.
And when a person is in sujud, provided
their sujud is proper. What this
narration means
is that Allah commanded him that when he
is in sujud only seven parts of his body
should be touching the ground and at
least these seven parts of his body must
be touching the ground in order for the
sujud to be considered
valid in order for it to be considered
whole and complete. What are those seven
places on the body? Who remembers this?
We did a whole
spiel on this a few nights ago.
[Arabic recitation]
more. Such a big guy and such a Ya. Come
on, man. Raise your voice. Yes, let's
hear it.
[Arabic recitation]
very important point because we
mentioned that a lot of people have the
habit of making sujud only on the head.
The head up here. But the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us that
He says a person's
not valid
in which his nose does not touch the
ground equally as his forehead does.
This narration is in who remembers where
this narration is in? That's too much,
right?
[Arabic recitation]
Good try. It was he gave it the old
college try. No, it's in sunny
it's rather obscure for most people.
So yes, it's the forehead with the
nose. So we understand from this that
the sujud is on the face. It's not on
the head. Right? Who remembers the dua
of the prophet Sam?
My face has made sujud face face right
not the So when a person is to make
sujud the face is what is making sujud
not the top of the head here not the it
is the face that is making sujud and the
sunnah is that he would
he would place his weight on his face
and on his nose. You know people
sometimes ask questions when we say
these things they'll ask questions like
what if a person is unable right that
question can go for everything we are
speaking about the most optimum
most complete way in the most
favorable of circumstances this is how
it should be right
however except ceptions occur when we we
narrow it down to specific people.
That's a different story. Okay. So,
we've got the first one which is the
forehead and the nose. We have six
more to go.
[Arabic recitation]
Well, is there a difference? There is a
difference. But the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said,
Al keen.
So
alphane are the two palms with the
fingers. All right. This is the kef
here. These are the this is the kef. And
so the word palm is very important here
when we say kef. Why? What if a person
makes sujud with their hands this
on the ground, the back of their hand on
the ground? What about if they make
sujud with their fists on the ground
you know some kind of tough guy or
something? Or what if they make sujud
with the tips of their fingers, right?
And you'd think that I'm making this up.
I've seen all of this actually in real
life. however, this is all incorrect.
It is supposed to be the palms and
the the inside of the the the the hand
and the fingers should be pointing which
direction
[Arabic recitation]
everything faces towards the by default
take that as a principle why because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said in a very
general command.
[Silence]
Any
direction you
direct yourself,
Allah says to him belongs the the the
east and the west. Any direction you
face there you will find the face of
Allah. Is that what it means? Does this
mean that Allah is everywhere? He's in
every direction simultaneously. Is he
omniresent? Is that what that means?
foram.
[Silence]
And so this verse is not a verse of the
attributes of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah's face, the face of Allah. It is
one of the attributes of Allah, but it
is in other verses. This verse is to be
translated as in the correct opinion
that any direction you face then that is
the direction of salah for the
acceptance of your prayer of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So this statement
point yourself to the center of alas
haram or point yourself direct yourself
to the direction of al masjid alam.
Okay,
from this verse we understand what the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
understood and that is every part of my
body which is possible to face towards
the
I face towards the so when he would
stand in salah his feet would be facing
towards the his chest would be facing
towards the when he would raise his
hands to make he wouldn't do this he
wouldn't do this or you know people do
all kinds of stuff He he wouldn't do
this, right? He would raise his hands
this with his palms facing towards
the either the height of his shoulders
or the height of his ears. Allahbar,
right? His face would be towards the all
parts of his body would be for towards
the injur
his hands would be towards the His
fingers would be pointed towards the
Okay, so we have three. What are the
next two?
We have three. The knees, right?
And a person might think well you know
how how could you mess that up right the
two niece but it is possible and that is
as alkari mentions that in his prophet
sallaiam
in the Arabic language is to make
distance between two things.
meaning that his thighs would not touch
his stomach and the backs of his thighs
where the hamstrings are would not touch
the back the backs of his calves. He
wouldn't be together this. He would
be open. It would be shaped this
when he was in sujud sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. So the thighs are distant from
the stomach. The feet or the legs are
distant from each other. The backs
the calves are separated from the
backs of the thighs. This is how he
would make sujud sallallam.
His arms
would be separated from the sides from
his sides. Now we again are speaking
about the most optimum prayer. This is
how his prayer was described because he
would always pray in front by himself.
He wouldn't pray in a row. If a person
is in the row, it's not possible to do
this without
you know in infringing on other
people's space.
So when a person is in in the row, he is
to make himself as malleable as possible
in order to not
you know infringe on the other
person's space to his right or to his
left. For instance,
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam says
in Abdah
He said that the best of you in are
those who have the softest shoulders in
the row or the most malleable shoulders
in the row.
And what's meant by this is that when
they're standing, they don't stand in a
way that is going to disturb the people
beside them. Sometimes people they come
to make salah Allahbar and then they
want to stand this right what is
going on here with this everybody has to
deal now with this person sticking their
elbows in their chest and stick this is
inappropriate it's disturbing it's it's
not the sunnah in any way in this way
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would command the companions to be
malleable with one another to fit into
each each other. Likewise, the meaning
of this narration
is
meaning when the im is straightening the
row and he tells someone to come forward
or to step back a bit to make the row
straight that the person listens and
takes instruction from the imam.
Both of these meanings the scholars
mention in explaining this narration
because sometimes you'll tell someone
come forward a little bit and they'll
look at you like
you know who are you to tell me what to
do I'm perfect everything is perfect
right now right this is and they'll
become a little bit stubborn
when the imam is to say come forward
come back as a matter of fact this is A
this is a responsibility
of the imam to straighten the row and if
the row is not straight because of his
negligence he is held to account.
So, let me tell you something that maybe
we've heard of before. The word,
right? Straighten your rows. Become
straight with one another. It's not just
a it's not just a
you know just something you say when you
go to lead salah because we hear in the
haram when the imam goes to lead he says
and then we go to pray I've seen a man
stand next to another man there's only
two of them there's a guy he's leading
salah there's one guy next to him and
when he goes to lead salah he says but
who are is talking to it's just you and
the guy next to you.
This is just now become just something
we say. It has no meaning,
[Arabic recitation]
say when you go to lead salah. To the
point that if you do not say it, if I
were to just stand here in the front and
just start salah, many people might
think, wait, he didn't say anything,
right? But that is the sunnah. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
only say these things when he was
teaching them and giving them
instruction.
After that he wouldn't say anything. He
would just stand and say and begin
salah. And so most of his time he never
said these things. This was only when he
instructed them asb mentioned.
However, when he was teaching them to
make their rose straight,
he would walk through the rose. Imagine
this. Every
he would go through the rose himself one
by one. All the men's rows and
straighten the rose himself. Walk down
the rows. Each one he was described as
if he were making arrows. As if he were
making them so straight that you could
shoot an arrow straight down and not
touch anyone with that arrow. This is
how straight he would make it. This
this process of straightening the row
himself, how long do you think that
took?
Imagine every salah he would stand and
go through the row and make it straight.
How long do you think something like
this would take?
Maybe 10 minutes, maybe 15, 20 minutes
before he would start the prayer. He was
not permitted to start the prayer until
the rows were perfectly straight. As a
matter of fact, this was so important to
Allah that one of his miracles
that were given to him, aside from all
the other miracles he had, is that he
was able to simultaneously during prayer
watch the companions while he was faced
away from them to make sure their rows
were straight throughout the prayer.
Have any of us heard of this before?
Maybe some of us have, some of us
haven't. And
one of the things that Allah gave him is
that when he would stand to lead salah
and the companions were behind him and
he had straightened the rose while he
was in salah, he was able to watch them
at the same time. The whole salah. Why?
just to make sure that there's not a
problem with the way that the rows are
straight throughout prayer saiam
this is how important this issue is it
is incredibly important as a matter of
fact in the time of
he had people that he designated for
each prayer to go through the rows
because of course the masid expanded
there were a huge amount of people
making every salah and they would go
through the rows and straighten the rows
and he would not begin until each of
them would pass up word that the rows
are straight now you can start
now imagine if we started to do that
here right we're not going to pray till
the imam has made sure that our row and
a half is straight how impatient would
people get with something that,
right? This is something that is unheard
of. What are you doing? Just start the
salah. Come on. We got stuff to do. We
are busy people, right? We got a lot of
important things to get to. And so these
are some of the
lost sun
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. But what the point that we're
making is that when a person is in the
prayer in the row,
they are to make themselves as malleable
as possible with the people next to
them. And they are always to take
instruction from the imam because the
imam is not only the leader in the
salah. He's the leader in every aspect
of the prayer. When it comes to how
people stand, how they pray, who stands
before the others. In the early days in
Medina, the women would pray behind the
men. The men were very, very poor. They
were suffering from famine and war and
illness and so they were in tatters and
a lot of them were so poor they couldn't
even cover themselves properly and so
the women were not permitted to stand up
from sujud until the men had completely
stood up. Why? Because if they stood up
before the men in front of them, they
may see some part of their body that
that you know comes out of their their
they had so little clothing that you
know if they just changed their position
some of their may show.
So these are all instructions that he
would give to the companions. Salah was
a big thing. It was not a little thing.
Salah was a huge deal. Every salah,
one of the things that is so sad about
our time, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said that the first thing we
would lose as a nation
when we
go off of the path and stray from the
path of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
That's one of the first or last things
we would lose is our prayer. What does
that mean? We would lose our prayer.
Meaning we it would just be hollow just
something we do. Doesn't matter how it's
done, right? Nobody's focused. Aan is
just a formality. Whoever leads salah
now the idea that we have for
instance in America a lot of times is an
imam is what the guy that is the
community organizer he's the he's the
social butterfly right he goes and gives
talks in different places and he travels
and he but the masid that he's actually
the imam of he's hardly ever there and
most of the prayers he's not there he's
absent right Because the idea is anybody
can lead salah. What's the big deal? We
could have a 16-year-old kid come and
lead salah. That's not a problem.
Anybody can lead salah. It's not
important. Just anybody just get it
done. As a matter of fact, we'd rather
have just anybody lead salah who has a
really nice voice than have someone
who has a lesser voice but is a a
scholar or somebody that should lead us
in salah. What is salah? What is J? The
companions used to describe salah in
Jama as
[Silence]
the prophet prayed for us. What does
that mean? For us,
for us, they're talking about let us in
for us. Meaning, we all stand behind the
im. And it's as if we're saying, "Oh
Allah,
here we are gathered in your house. We
are desperate for your mercy. This is
the best amongst us. Please accept from
us." That is what leading salah is.
That's the significance of it. This is
the best amongst us. He knows the most
of your words and he has embodied the
most of your revelation from amongst us
here. So please accept from us. Whatever
he says it is on our behalf and we say
that is what
is.
However the companions the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. They would
never allow someone to lead salah
whenever there was someone more
knowledgeable present unless he was the
fixed im. Right?
for
[Silence]
he said
Muslim
the person who leads in prayer is the
one who has memorized and practices is
the most of the Quran. Listen, he said,
he didn't say the most memorized.
He said the most recited amongst them,
meaning the one who has memorized and
understood and embodied the teachings of
the Quran the most amongst them. This is
not just root memorization.
That's not what is intended here.
Because in the language of the
companions, in the language of hadith,
they never they did not have someone
amongst them who learned and memorized
the Quran, who didn't understand what it
meant and implemented. This didn't exist
with them. Do we understand? So by
default, if a person has memorized
more of the Quran, he is by default more
knowledgeable and more practicing
because the way that the companions
memorize the Quran is they would come
learn 10 verses and stop.
And they would not come back for 10 more
until they had learned all that those
verses intended and meant,
implemented whatever there was to
implement, asked whatever questions
there were to ask, and embodied those 10
verses as much as possible. This is why
it took Abdullahb Omar how many years to
memorize Bakar? Who knows?
12 10 10 years in 10 years and then he
slaughtered a cow after out of thanks to
Allah subhanahu wa tala Ibar
the great scholar and son of
took 10 years to memorize bakar
why
because they didn't just memorize things
he would learn 10 verses And now he has
to go and sit with the companions to
make sure that he investigates every
corner of every verse till he has
exhausted every question that he has
with regards to the meanings of those 10
verses. That is a process. Sometimes it
takes months. Right? And so the point
here is that when the prophet tells us
The one who is most recited of the
Quran, it means memorization, it means
implementation, it means knowledge,
right? He says, "Sallam,
and if they are all the same in the
Quran, then the most knowledgeable
amongst them in the Sunnah, in his
sunnah. And if they are all the same in
the sunnah, then the first of them to
make hijra.
And if they are all the same in hijra,
then the oldest amongst them. The
scholars the fuk say even though this
is incredibly unlikely. I mean going
through all of those is you know
who are we dealing with you know
identical twins for us to not find our
imam out of that. But even past that, it
would be the best of them in character.
Those who have the best character that
that is the rigor and that is the
qualifications
to lead salah even if it's just two
people. So the companions when they
would go to have someone lead them in
salah, they're traveling or they're out
or whatever it is, they would see who is
of them most knowledgeable, most
memorized of the Quran. They would have
him lead salah. Have you ever seen that
before? Have you ever seen people meet
up in the masid and ask each other how
much of the Quran do you know to
identify their im?
No. You know even when he would bury
people sai wasallam he would ask who of
them was most recited of the Quran and
he would put him in his grave firstbas
because we can bury pe you know more
than one person in each grave right put
two people three people four people in
in one grave. The point is is that when
he would go to put them in the grave, he
would ask
which of them had memorized more of the
Quran. They would tell him this one and
he would start with them. That is how he
buried the martyrs of of saiam
as jab tells us in
these are things that we lost. Why did
we lose these things? Why? because this
doesn't mean much to us anymore. We have
to make it mean something again. We have
to make it that each prayer is memorable
and it was never any prayer before
it and it'll never be repeated again. It
was a special moment that existed
outside of space and time. I completely
forgot myself. I lost myself in the
abyss of this prayer. I lost track of
time. Sorry, I was praying.
That is what we're talking about. That
is the kind of people that the
companions were. When we read about our
forefathers, that's where they started.
Anyways, we have exhausted our time and
nobody got to ask any questions. You
guys just let me keep asking you
questions. I'll end with this. Yes, we
could take a one question. Huh? Go
ahead.
So
[Arabic recitation]
kind of unrelated but you're standing
like
my understanding was always the
requirement is being shouldertoshoulder
[Arabic recitation]
just what's the requirement for
filling the gaps part of
Well, in andah alkari
narrated that he would watch the
companions how they would straighten
their row. You have to remember the rows
there were no lines in the carpets.
Okay? There wasn't any carpet actually.
It was just the the it was a dirt floor,
right? And so how would they straighten
their row?
Ib said, "I would see the companions of
the prophet."
[Silence]
He said, "When they would straighten
their rows, I would see each of them
would touch the ankle of the man next to
him and the knee of the knee of the man
next to him and the shoulder of the
shoulder of the of the man next to him."
Now, this doesn't mean that throughout
the entirety of salah your ankles and
your knees are touching each other. Some
people have understood that and that is
not necessarily correct.
Allah mentions in when he explained this
narration that this is to initially
straighten the row
because the foot the foot everybody has
differentized feet. If I make it how
long the foot is if I try to make my toe
I'm going to be back a step if my feet
are bigger right? If it is the heel,
same thing. The ankle is the exact
center of a person's skeleton of their
of their center of gravity. If I
straighten my ankle with the ankle of
the person next to me, that is as
straight as the row is going to be. Now,
they wouldn't continue and maintain
contact
all the way through prayer. That would
be almost impossible, incredibly
distracting and uncomfortable at the
least. However, they would begin like
that and then the feet would would take
their natural place. The the knees
would take their natural place, but the
shoulders will always stay touching in
prayer. That's the answer to that
question. What's the second one?
[Arabic recitation]
you explained how to properly
He also said that the prophet said
all those things the C not etc.
he would be praying alone on the
front. So then and then you also said
that
difficult what do we do if we're
all in a row and then you said might
[Arabic recitation]
without
transgressing into the space of the
people next to you
as much of that as possible. So what
does that mean? for instance, my
legs,
my calves not touching the back of my
thighs, my thighs not touching my
stomach, my elbows, my forearms not
touching the ground. I'm able to do all
those things in in the row. I'm not able
to open my arms up this when I'm in
the row, right? I'm not able to maybe
take as wide a birth with my knees as I
as I naturally would. But you do as much
of that as possible without
you know transgressing into another
person's space. Yes. Doctor Marwan our
homegrown I don't know about homegrown
but our doctor. Yes.
Very very informative since we spoke
about straightening the lines. I mean
one practical issue we have sometimes
with the brothers and I was one of them
at some point who are sitting on chairs.
[Arabic recitation]
listening to their sermon but also
during the prayer they have some knees
and medical pain. So I always we have an
issue you know how do we straighten the
lines when some of us are also sitting
you know are praying while sitting.
[Arabic recitation]
that question.
So, I'll turn that over to you guys.
What do you think? Where should the
chairs be positioned
in the row?
Imagine yourself in my place. Now,
what would your answer be? If the if the
chairs are to be put in the row, we have
two options, right? We either have
the feet
in the same place and the person is back
or we have the person is there but the
feet are coming up into the front. Which
one do we do? How do we straighten the
road with the chairs?
[Arabic recitation]
something? Was it Jam? No.
hips. He is He's getting fancy. Yes.
Abu Ali
shoulders. Okay. Anybody else? A lot of
times you find that people will
straighten their feet. They'll put their
feet right here and they're sitting
behind the rope. This is categorically
incorrect.
This is exactly wrong. Okay.
It is the chest, the shoulders that
remain in the rope. Everything else that
comes back or forth, that is not what
has to be maintained in maintaining the
role. That's inconsequential
because people used to sit in the
prophet's time in the row, didn't they?
Weren't there sick people that were
sitting down? They didn't have chairs. I
mean, some of them did. How many of us
have ever imagined the Prophet Muhammad
speaking on a chair, sitting in the
masid on a chair? No one. He had a chair
that he used to sit on and teach in.
However, the point here is that
when they would sit, they would sit
for instance, Muawia after he was
someone attempted to kill him when
when he was stabbed at the same time
that Ali was attacked. He was stabbed
in the hip. He's a he was a kind of a
big guy, right? And so he was stabbed in
the hip. After that he would pray with
his foot forward. Okay, that foot
forward would come way past the the row
around him.
That's inconsequential. That doesn't
matter. The companions always prayed
that. Even if I just sit down like
I'm inhood, my knees are coming up in
front of the rope. It's always was the
chest. And the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam when he would go through
the rows to straighten them he would
straighten them with the chest
and he would determine someone is out of
place when their chest was out of place.
So the chair is supposed to be placed in
a way that the person's chest is in line
with the chest of the people next to
him. But here's the issue. What about if
a person only uses the chair to sit to
to make ru or sjud then but they're
standing most of the time then what do
we do?
Anyone know?
[Arabic recitation]
you
people just use the chair you know when
they're prostrating
[Arabic recitation]
be in the same line based on their
chest. I mean just I guess
[Arabic recitation]
a person is using the chair only for rur
or sjud.
Okay
but they're standing straight. The chair
if they stand straight in the row is
going to be coming out behind them. And
the question people have is, well, what
about the people that make the row
behind them?
We can't watch out for everything,
right? We have to make a decision. It
has to be one or the other. And so the
road is to be straight with the chest
always straight no matter what the
situation in the standing position.
If the row behind is impeded by the
chair, they skip that place. They skip
that spot as if there were a pillar
there or as if there were some object
there. That's not an issue. Or they
would step back a row and complete the
row without the chair being in their way
if there's room in the masid. But if
there's not room in the masid, they just
skip that place, right? That's not a big
deal. always in the standing position.
Everyone is in the rope is in line with
each other. It is the chest. It is the
shoulders. So, I will end it there. The
idea of this Saturday night question
and answer is for us to have a
discussion we are.
And the idea is for it to go,
I'm hoping between 20 and 30 minutes
only because every other night we we try
to go between 10 and 15 minutes for the
right. That's just me speaking. But if
you have questions throughout the week,
you want to ask them, you want to
prepare them. You want to ask your
wives, your sisters, your daughters,
whatever to write them down. They have
any question. It's being livereamed as
well. It's being recorded and
documented. then you prepare for it
Saturday night half an hour but don't
feel compelled to sit the whole session
if you have something to do by all means
you know go about your business
inshallah if you want to catch the rest
of it on the live stream that's why we
do this it's not for me to become a a
celebrity I'm trying not to do that it
is a it is a it's a service for our
community here that's why it's going on
on the internet, right? It's a service
for us here that if a person can't be
with us, they can catch it on the feed
or they can go and and find the archives
of everything. So, if after a half
hour or 20 minutes or 10 minutes you
have something to do, don't feel
compelled to stay the entire time if
you're unable. But if you just feel that
whisper in the back of your head saying,
"Hey, come on. Let's get out of here."
That I want you to fight against. fight
that. But if you have genuinely
something to do, then Allah
Alhamdulillah.